le loir-et-cher toujours avec ce nouveau
projet dévoilé par le chef doublement
étoilé christophe est il quittera son
établissement de montlivault pour
rejoindre fleurs de loire 4500 mètres
carrés au coeur de blois en lieu et
place de l'epa de gaston d'orléans un
ensemble haut de gamme comprenant le
premier hôtel cinq étoiles du
département un restaurant gastronomique
une pâtisserie un bistrot un spa
ouverture prévue en juin 2022 christophe
ait annoncé son projet aujourd'hui sur
les réseaux sociaux samuel colard
[Musique]
l'annoncent est enregistrée au château
de blois
entouré des architectes décoratrice
paysagiste et du promoteur du projet
christophe est présente fleurs de loire
le double étoilé déménage à blois pour
prendre la main sur un complexe haut de
gamme
après quinze mois de travaux en lieu et
place de l'ehpad récemment fermé gaston
d'orléans
il y aura un restaurant gastronomique
bien sûr qui sera au coeur du bâtiment
dans la partie centrale au premier étage
de façon à voir la vue sur la loire
et puis il y aura évidemment un hôtel
tout autour avec 44 chambres et puis un
spa sur deux niveaux de sous-sols et le
rez-de-chaussée sur 600 m² c'est le chef
veut s'agrandir mais gardez l'esprit de
montlivault là bas les lieux deviennent
trop étroit pour son équipe
trente-deux personnes travaillent dans
ses deux restaurants aujourd'hui quatre
fois plus qu'à l'ouverture en 2014
mais avec fleurs de loire il se
retrouverait également aux commandes
d'un des rares hôtels cinq étoiles de la
région
concrètement il y en a très peu
aujourd'hui en région centre il y en a
pas du tout dans le loir et cher
donc voilà on va être le premier cinq
étoiles du loir et cher mais voilà pour
moi ça reste ça reste la continuité de
ce qu'on a pu faire jusqu'à présent
continuité aussi avec les guides
gastronomiques christophe et devrait
conserver ses deux étoiles dans
l'édition du michelin 2023 l'ouverture
du nouveau restaurant est elle prévue
six mois avant en juin 2020